is it possible to have a healthy
sleep life
without the regularities
i say that
because i'm all over the place yeah and
i've gotten good in being all over the
place
so i'll often like what happens i'll go
stretches of time there'll be sometimes
a month
where i my days are like this is
embarrassing to admit but
they're like just you and i here just
you and i it's like 28 hours or 30 hour
days yeah
like i'll just go all the way around
comfortably and happily i love it and
then there'll be a nap i mean if you
like add up the hours
when i'm just like sleeping as much
as i want it'll probably be like six
hour average per 24 hours
like that kind of yeah so it works out
nicely maybe even seven hours i don't
know but
that it's obviously irregular and
there's chaos in the whole thing right
like
sometimes a shorter sleeve sometimes
it's longer is that
is that totally not a good thing do you
think
the best evidence that we have to speak
to this question is people who are doing
rotating shifts
and
unfortunately the news is not good um
they usually have a higher instance of
many diseases such as
depression diabetes cardiovascular
disease obesity
stroke
and
[Music]
and again i'm
that's just me communicating the data
that we we have and i'm not telling you
that you should do anything different
the other
thing is that there's nothing in your
biology
that suggests that that's how your body
was designed to sleep
um it is a system that
loves habit you know
if
if your circadian clock in your brain
it's called the suprachiasmatic nucleus
sits in the middle of your brain had a
personality trait it would be a creature
of habit
it loves habit
that's how your biology is designed to
work is through very archetypal
prototypical expected cycles
and
when we
when we do something different to that
then
you start to see some of the pressure
stress fractures in the system
but again
to your point
if that's something that you don't mind
you know
adopting and understanding and
then i think you should keep doing what
you're doing it's complicated you of
course have to be a student of your own
body and explore it one of the reasons i
want to have kids
is kids enforces a stricter schedule
i think i definitely so i've had
i i definitely feel that i'm um
not living the
sort of
data wise scientifically speaking the
optimal life
and me just living the way i want to
live day to day is perhaps not the
optimal way and there's certain things
that i've seen very successful people
that i
know in my life when they get when they
have kids
they actually their productivity goes up
they get their together there's a
lot of aspects that have everything yeah
yeah the regularity i mean that creature
is a habit that's the thing that that
that's power and then you start to
optimally use the hours you have in the
day let me ask you about actually i just
have one quick point on that too you
know we often think about
sleep as a cost
but instead i think of sleep as an
investment
and the reason is because your
effectiveness and your efficiency when
you're well slept
typically exceeds that when you're not
and to me it's the idea of if i'm going
to boil a pot of water
why would i boil it
on medium when i could boil it in half
the time on high
yeah and i sometimes worry that when i
speak to fortune 500 companies and you
know they're of this mentality of
you know longer hours getting people to
rise and grind
the first point is that after about 20
hours of being awake a human being is as
cognitively as impaired as they would be
if they were legally drunk
and
the reason i bring that point up is
because i don't know any
company or ceo who would say
i've got this great team they're drunk
all the time
but we often
lord the airport warrior who's flown
through three different time zones in
the past two days is on email at two am
and then is you know in the office at
six
and i think there is some aspect not in
all people but there is sort of some
aspect of that slight sleep machismo
and and that's not what you are very
different you know you are driven by
a purity of passion and a very authentic
incredibly genuine goal of wanting to do
something remarkable with your life
that's not the issue i think i'm i'm
speaking about
it's just simply that i think the
this notion of wanting to be awake for
longer to try and get more done
right can sometimes be at odds with the
fact that
you can actually get so much more done
if you're well slept and it's this
trade-off
i actually admire people that take the
big risk and work hard whether that
means staying up late at night all those
kinds of things
but it cannot be in in the framework in
the context like what edison said which
is sleep feels like a waste of time
so like if you're not sleeping because
you think sleep is stupid that's totally
wrong
but if you're not sleeping because
you're deeply passionate about something
that to me it's a it's a gray area
of course but that to me is much more
admirable and it's everything you're
espousing is saying like
whatever the hell you're doing you
better be aware that sleep
long term and short term is really good
for you
so if you're not sleeping you're
sacrificing just make sure you're
sacrificing for the right thing
i i see vodka
and getting drunk the same way
i know it's not good for me i know i'm
not going to feel good
days after i know it's going to decrease
my performance and there's nothing
positive about it except
it introduces chaos in my life
that
introduces beautiful experiences that i
would not otherwise have it uh creates
like this
turmoil of social interaction that
ultimately
makes me happy that i've experienced
them in the moment and later at the
stories you get to meet new people it's
like alcohol in this society is is a
an incredible facilitator of that so
like that's a good example of like not
sleeping and drinking way too much vodka
again it's this notion of you know life
is to be lived to
a degree but you know if you do have
children um
i think one of the other things that
then maybe comes into the picture is the
fact that now
there are other people that you have to
live for
than yourself
yeah but come on like once they're old
enough like if you can't if you can't
defend for yourself you're too weak get
stronger it's gonna be that kind of
fatherhood yeah i got it
i'm understanding so much more about lex
freeman than uh
that's why you have to have uh your uh
for for me that would be my wife would
be probably softer it's good cop bad cop
because i think
uh
but of course actually because i don't
have kids i've seen some tough dudes
when they have
kids become this the the like the
softest the softies they become like
they do everything for their kids it has
become like it totally transforms their
life i mean joe rogan is an example of
that
i just seen so many tough guys
completely become changed
by having kids which is fascinating to
watch because it just shows you how
meaningful having kids is for a lot of
people although i would say having
you know um
chatted with joe for for some time um i
think he is a delightful sweetheart
independent of children i think
don't get me wrong i don't want to be in
a ring with him
he would face me five ways till tuesday
but um i think he's a desperately sweet
man and a very very smart individual
yeah i mean but he talks about the
compassion he's gained from realizing
just watching kids grow up that we were
all kids at some point you get a new new
perspective i think just like me i still
get this uh with him he's super
competitive and like there's a certain
way to approach life
like you're striving to do great things
and you're competitive against others
and that intensity of that aggression
um that
can lack compassion sometimes and
empathy and when you have children you
get
a sense like oh everybody was a child at
some point everybody was as a kid and
you see that whole development process
it can definitely enrich
um expand
your your
ability to be empathetic
you